it's hard to believe it's been almost
four years as we first heard the phrase
oculus rift yet in the intervening
months the team at oculus has done a lot
and I mean a lot of difficult thinking
about the way this thing should look and
the way this thing should feel so let's
take a trip down memory lane this one
which is my favorite because it's such a
monstrosity isn't even so much a design
prototype as it is a proof-of-concept
the team at oculus wanted to know
exactly what it would take to shoehorn
in all the things they wanted in the
consumer build into what was then the
form factor of one of their early
developer kits so here is when they also
started to think about different ways
that they could actually fix this thing
once was on your head what they started
to play with here was if you had this
thing on the back of your head you had
an elastic strap what if you had like a
almost a bike helmet style tightening
mechanism back here
it definitely secured it but again a lot
of moving parts wasn't necessarily
friendly this is called the Crescent Bay
prototype and it was the the last thing
that developers got to use to build
their games on before the retail unit
came out you can see that they figured
out what to do more or less with the
audio it was kind of an articulated
headphone piece that could swivel to fit
the ears of whoever was wearing it close
down on him or swing back up now this
one has seen better days but what you're
really finally getting is a sense of
those last design touches that became
available in the retail build they
started playing with putting a fabric
overlay around the eye box that's just
one of those approachability things so
buy this one the team at oculus was
trying to figure out how to account for
the fact that everyone's eyes are
slightly different widths apart it's
called interpupillary distance and
oculus wanted to make sure that the rift
would accommodate people who were within
the 5th and 95th percentile which brings
us to now more than three and a half
years after that very first ski goggles
strap prototype showed up at the e3 game
show it's the very real in the flesh
oculus rift of course you can see the
answer to all the questions that the
design team grappled with over time
there's the kind of curved feel to the
outside there's the fabric that wraps
the eye box to make it a little more
approachable if there's that integrated
audio solution that swivels back and
forth to account for different people's
ears that all goes to your computer
through this one slim
Heather now eventually we want this to
fall away we want to walk into the
Metaverse unimpeded but until then I'll
see you in virtual reality